c'est mentir je m'appelle gauthier
ça c'était une brève introduction petit
chéri je l'appelle gauthier donc
artistes en intelligence artificielle
j'ai pu m'intéresser à cette question en
iran et en est en apprenant fait en
apprenant via l'expérience est en fait
la question de l'intelligence
artificielle intelligence artificielle
c'est quelque chose qui aujourd'hui dont
tout le monde parle mais qui parle pas
forcément appel à tout le monde c'est
aussi quelque chose qui est au coeur de
tous les débats à tort ou à raison mais
moi ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est que vous avez mon avis qui un avis
qui est un peu naïf mais qui est en
forme et sur la question donc sa
découverte
elle mènera à la destruction des couches
inférieures de l'art l'artiste risque de
devenir une machine à clé à une autre
machine
la peinture est morte alors tout ça
c'est des citations qui ont été
prononcées aux alentours des années 1850
par des grands penseurs et à fond toute
référence à la même chose qui est
l'appareil photo c'est quelque chose qui
est très content aujourd'hui et pourtant
on pourrait on pourrait penser qu'elle
se rapporte à l'intelligence
artificielle alors si je décide de vous
parler de ça c'est parce que à l'époque
on parle d'un sujet qui fait peur on
parle d'un sujet qui donc nous on parle
mais que personne très peu de gens
comprennent et aborde un sujet qui fait
également river est en fait tous ces
aspects là on va essayer de les aborder
aujourd'hui avec l'intelligence
artificielle alors l'intelligence
artificielle quand on en parle c'est
important de définir ce que c'est parce
que c'est une notion qui est très vague
donc je vais vous donner ma définition
intelligence
ciel jusqu'au bout l'intelligence
artificielle c'est la conception de
systèmes intelligents
voilà
en gros je sais que ma réponse et vous
satisfait pas forcément et ça c'est
parce que là le problème il est valable
dans la définition de ce qu'est
l'intelligence artificielle en soit il
est dans la définition de ce qu'est
l'intelligence elle même et
l'intelligence et l'écriture à définir
prenez par exemple une tâche 5 qui
consisterait à discerner ce qui est un
chat d'un chien donc il faut d'abord
connaître les caractéristiques qui sont
spécifiques à un chat ou un chien il
faut réussir à généraliser ces
caractéristiques et ensuite faire des
comparaisons à partir de ça donc c'est
une tâche qui demande que l'intelligence
prenez maintenant une tâche qu'ils
veulent en vrai
par exemple de prendre la décision se
lancer dans des études pour par la suite
obtenir un diplôme et cet annuaire
professionnellement ça c'est une notion
qui prend beaucoup plus d'intelligence
ou alors une intelligence d'une autre
dimension et pourtant l'intelligence
artificielle ça vise à concevoir des
systèmes qui répondent à ces deux
problèmes
alors alors aujourd'hui on va on va
définir du coup l'intelligence
artificielle au travers de ce qu'on sait
faire
concrètement donc aujourd'hui on est
capable de répliquer les comportements
humains simple à l'aide d'algorithmes
qui sont des ensembles de grandir de
d'instruction basées sur des
statistiques et avec ses algorithmes on
peut répliquer donc des comportements
humains semblent ça ça ça peut être
utilisé plusieurs manières la première
manière
ça va être de faire de l'optimisation
par exemple de réaliser des calculs
complexes
une deuxième manière ça peut être de
faire des économies d'échelle par
exemple avec quelques exemples des
tchats bottes qui permettent
de remplir la tâche d'une équipe entière
de sav donc c'est ses applications
l'intelligence artificielle et visent
toutes les rockets en fait et c'est là
que naît le cadet connaissent tous les
tous les quiproquos autour de la
question d'intelligence artificielle
donc quand on parle d'intelligence
artificielle on parle d'intelligence
artificielle
on s'attend à quelque chose qui est
autrement plus grand parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on al'habitude de
fantasmer et on se rend compte que ce
que nous vendent les startups les
gouvernements et également les
entreprises c'est souvent d'intelligence
augmentée qui est vendu comme de
l'intelligence artificielle
alors avec les deux amis on a commencé
ce projet et on s'est demandé quel était
le meilleur moyen de 2 explorer cette
question d'intelligence artificielle ce
projet il aura il aura au cours de cours
de la route
il aura soulevé des grandes questions
notamment est ce qu une intelligence
artificielle peut être indépendante
est ce qu'une intelligence artificielle
peut être créative est ce qu une
intelligence artificielle peut remplacer
un artiste et est ce que à terme
d'intelligence artificielle remplacera
l'être humain et donc nous on a décidé
d'explorer sa au travers de l'art en
expérimentant alors pourquoi là c'est
une décision qui est un peu
qui en plus spécial je vous explique
pourquoi tout de suite alors la première
raison c'est que là ça offre des
résultats tangibles dont des résultats
observa on peut on peut observer des
résultats les peler matérialiser ensuite
l'intelligence partie l'art pardon ça
offre savons qu'une piste qui est
accessible en fait tout le monde est
plus ou moins familier avec l'art à sa
manière avec une forme d'art en plus de
ça ça offre un terrain de jeu qui est
différent du terrain scientifique
puisque sa hotte des résultats qui sont
interprétable donc en fait au lieu
d'avoir des oui et non on obtient des
oui mais des noms mais qu'il faut mettre
des débats qui sont parfois plus
intéressant que la réponse elle même et
enfin c'est une pratique qui est
totalement libre donc en fait en
expérimentant avec là on risque pas de
se faire
cerné par sa propre créativité et on
peut se laisser surprendre par les
résultats qu'il obtient alors ça c'est
pas un an
quand je parle de large part de beaucoup
de formes d'art dont ceux spécialisés
plutôt dans la dans la peinture et de la
génération d'image mais ça peut aussi
être la musique ça peut être la création
de de musique avec des interactions
entre humains et algorithmes ça peut
être tout ce qui lie aux textes donc la
rédaction de scénarios
ça peut être là la création de parole
musique et ça peut quand je le dis est
la génération d'image je vous propose
est aujourd'hui faire un petit exercice
pour comprendre le processus de
créativité le vrai processus de
créativité qu'on essaie d'inculquer à la
machine
en fait la créativité il faut la voir
comme une espèce de chaîne qui possède
le maillon et tous ces maillots on va
essayer de les remplacer en les
automatisant bien des algorithmes et
tous les projets qu'on voie d'être
autour de nous que ce soit dans la
musique dans le cinéma ou dans l'art en
fait si longtemps le commun
d'automatiser certains de ses oreilles
alors je vais vous demander de vous
mettre dans la peau d'un algorithme
auquel on va demander d'apprendre à
créer une image à partir de rien vous
êtes sans rien on vous demande de créer
une image
le résultat concret obtenir ça a quelque
chose qui va ressembler à ça ce qu'on a
vu avant en fait un écran non merci
maintenant si on si on donne la décence
à cet algorithme si on lui donne la vue
l'odorat le toucher
ça va lui donner un accès en fait à tout
les poneys qui va permettre
un début d'apprentissage donc ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle la vision par
ordinateur et en fait c'est dans notre
casse avec l'analyse d'une image pixel
par pixel pour en déduire des formes des
couleurs ce qui va permettre à
l'algorithme d'avoir une base pour
apprendre donc imaginez maintenant qu'on
vous montre une image si on vous demande
de créer une image à partir de ça il ya
beaucoup de chances que ce que vous
ressortiez ce soit c'était l'image
donc voilà banque prévoit qu'à partir
d'une image
il est très dur d'apprendre à créer une
image ma part entière puisque c'est
notre seule référence enquête maintenant
on peut imaginer que si on montrant
qu'en montrant plusieurs images donc des
images qui sont qui son corps et qui
sont qui sont corrélés qui sont qui sont
pas totalement différentes l'une de
l'autre
l'algorithme va pouvoir commencer à
apprendre à discerner des traits communs
des couleurs commune
il va pouvoir arriver à un résultat qui
va ressembler à quelque chose comme ça
alors ça c'est le résultat de ce système
cognitif qui s'appelle les cannes les
générative adversaire network et segal
ils permettent en fait à partir d'un
très grand nombre d'image dont existons
timmy l'image de créer une image
nouvelle en apprenant justement grâce au
cambdoge de nos cas la vision par
ordinateur alors qu'ils ont des
particularités ses algorithmes notamment
une particularité qui est aussi une
image est différente de toutes les
autres iron lady arrêtés automatiquement
ils sont une particularité qui est
propre à la créativité c'est que en fait
à chaque fois qu'ils vont créer quelque
chose ils vont créer quelque chose qui
est entièrement nouveau ça peut être
basée sur les mêmes données et ça peut
être avec les mêmes formules chaque
expérience donnera quelque chose de
nouveau et ça c'est propre à la
créativité humaine puisque peut pas
demander à quelqu'un de créer la même
chose te vois en même temps et entre les
deux voies en garde on leur a demandé
créer quelque chose
en fait les facteurs qui vont influencer
cette créativité ils vont en différé par
des pondérations différentes un an pour
compliquer un peu les choses et on peut
demander un algorithme de créer une
image qui soit paix alors comment on va
faire ça sachant que l'algorithme il a
aucune idée de cette notion de beauté
qui est complètement subjective alors ce
qu'on utilise pour faire ça c'était la
belle en fait chacune des images qu'on
va montrer à l'algorithme on va aller
labellisés comme étant plaisante ou très
peu plaisante à partir de ça on va
pouvoir apposer des sorte de filtre est
en fait orienté l'apprentissage de la
bri pour l'amener à créer un résultat
qui est basée plus sur les photos qu'on
a considéré comme étant présente
maintenant qu'on peut encore compliquer
les choses et on peut demander à
l'algorithme de créer une image qui soit
utile alors qu'on crée une image utile
on peut l'espérer s'en sortir encore une
fois avec les lamelles et faire
comprendre à l'algorithme une image peut
faire passer une émotion qu'une image
peut provoquer une réaction peut rendre
prise peut rendre heureux
toutes ces choses là alors là on est on
rentre dans le très théorique puisque
pour l'instant les recherches on n'y est
pas encore là et en fait on peut espérer
avec ça et avec un très très grand
nombre de données permettre un
algorithme te créer quelque chose qui
fasse passer l'émotion
après si on si on pousse encore
l'exercice un peu plus grands on peut
demander à l'algorithme de créer quelque
chose qui soit qui reflète sa
personnalité
alors pour ça il faudrait que
l'algorithme développe des 13
personnalités qu'ils estiment que ces
traits de personnalité sont différents
de ceux de la masse qu'il attribue à ses
traits des traits physiques et des
couleurs et qui réussissent à
retranscrire ça comme une image et ça
pour l'instant n'aurait pas du tout les
modèles pour le verre et du coup on est
on est un petit peu loin de connaître
donc comme vous le voyez la créativité
ça peut ça peut être résumé en huit
étapes qui permettent qui sont le plus
humble complexe et qui permettent de
créer quelque chose d'entièrement
nouveau à la manière d'un humain
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout sûr de
tout ce qui compose cette chaîne de
créativité et on a on n'a pas du tout
les modèles pour répliquer chacun de ces
chacun de ses baguettes
alors je vous ai parlé des gannes mais
bien sûr il ya beaucoup d'autres modèles
qui permettent
d'explorer la créativité mais ceci c'est
ce qui attire le plus de cas tire le
plus de tirs d'attention auprès de la
communauté scientifique
alors on a pris l'exemple d'une fleur
mais on peut également créer des
paysages entier on peut aussi créer des
portraits donc c'est une technologie qui
est qui est vraiment large et en fait à
partir du mans suffisamment de données a
montré qu'on peut créer quelque chose
qui est qui est entièrement nouveau à
partir de cette année alors si on fait
le point on est capable de créer des
images qui sont nouvelles de créer des
images qui sont uniques et de créer des
images qui sont ressemblante à la
réalité
donc je vous laisse imaginer les
opportune les opportunités économiques
qui a derrière je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup d'étudiants au business as dans
la salle est aussi demande de la société
active donc je crée cette partie du
boulot et moi je vais concentrer sur les
conséquences quelles vont être les
conséquences de l'arrivée d'une telle
technologie sur le marché
alors pour ça je vous propose de revenir
aux parallèles que j'ai fait avec la
photo donc la photographie ça a permis
d'automatiser le processus de
reproduction du coup ça a permis
d'automatiser le processus de production
et ça a eu pour effet
de ne presque supprimer une profession
qui les ailes d'artistes piste qui était
plutôt répandue avant la côte est on a
vu naître une toute nouvelle génération
de créative qui sont les les artistes
photographes et aujourd'hui il ya qu'à
l'ouvrir instagram pour voir que
n'importe qui peut être un artiste
photographe à sa manière alors là c'est
plus le processus de reproduction
automatise mais c'est bien le processus
de création et en automatisant le
processus de création il ya beaucoup de
chance touche les professions qui sont
par définition créative donc ces
professions ça peut être les web
designers et graphistes et j'en passe
mais ces professions ça va pas les faire
disparaître ça va juste pour fournir un
nouvel outil un outil on peut voir comme
en espèces de pinceau algorithmique mon
stylo algorithmique
valoriser pour les musiciens et en fait
ce nouvel outil va permettre aux
artistes et aux créatifs d'être
justement plus créative et plus
productive donc c'est quelque chose qui
en soi n'est jamais les belles choses et
on peut imaginer voir la même chose
s'est passé avec la photo avec justement
l'intelligence artificielle donc en
ayant que tout ça ensemble aujourd'hui
on peut se dire que si jamais on se
demande si l'intelligence artificielle
sera l'artiste de demain bah on peut
simplement répond est-ce que l'appareil
photo et l'artiste aujourd'hui peut-être
toujours est il que l'artiste reste un
frein segment humain alors on peut on
peut s'intéresser à la science en tête
ces modèles ils sont ils sont très
jeunes et ils vont être amenés à
développer dans le futur
ces modèles ils vont évoluer et la
science c'est quelque chose qui en quête
de vérité en fait qui pas du tout en
quête de ce qu'on veut entendre pour
pour comprendre qu'ils lisent qui peut
se passer plus tard
vachon en fait dans les applications
qu'on fait de cette science et pour ça
j'ai un seul mot à dire c'est
bienveillance donc ses applications et
dans les fêtes avec bienveillance
si maintenant il se pose la question des
skull main est ce que la machine va
remplacer l'humain on peut se dire
qu'avec une dose suffisante de
bienveillance la machine va remplacer
l'humain d'aujourd'hui mais seulement
vous permettre à l'humain demain de
prospérer en permettant à chacun d'être
un peu plus un artiste à sa manière
merci
[Applaudissements]